your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies dear laureates ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of Professor Jim
Erickson and myself I wish to express
our heartfelt appreciation to the novel
Assembly of the Kerensky Institute and
the Nobel foundation cancer has been the
number one cause of death during the
last half-century the trends is getting
even worse as the average lifespan
increases the concept of cancer
immunotherapy was theoretically proposed
by the Australian Nobel laureates Sir
Frank
MacFarlane Burnet over 60 years ago
since then a large number of people have
tried a polite but without success this
was probably because their efforts
focused on pushing the accelerator of
the immune system
Jimmy and I independently discovered the
reactivation of the immune system by
blocking two major negative regulators
ctla-4 and PD one can cure a significant
portion of cancer patients
fortunately our experiment in mouse
models was successfully applied to
humans as a result Jim and I have
experienced many occasions
that have made us feel well rewarded
such as meeting cancer patient who say
their lives were saved for our therapies
cancer immunotherapy is possible because
we have a highly sophisticated immune
system called acquired immunity which
can catch small changes in tumor cells
how could we develop such a
sophisticated immune recognition system
that employs gene rearrangement the
genetic reagent rearrangement mechanism
must have evolved accidentally probably
about 500 million years ago when
vertebrates evolved thereafter it must
have persisted through natural selection
due to the advantage of a surviving
infectious diseases considering that
chance of such mutation and selection
must be unbelievably low we human beings
are very fortunate Jim and I both know
that development of our discovery is
just beginning
as currently only 20 to 30 percent of
patients respond to the immunotherapy
and eco gram and Unchained described our
discovery the cancer equivalent of
penicillin which gave rise to a
generation of antibiotics that change
the medicine and consigned most
previously fatal in fact
to history we encourage many more
scientists to join us in our efforts to
keep improving cancer immunotherapy we
sincerely hope this treatment will reach
far and wide so that everybody on our
planet can benefit from this
evolutionary gift for healthy life Jim
and I acknowledge that we are selected
for this highest of the all scientific
honors we accept the distinction with
our deepest gratitude gratitude for the
great institutions that have supported
our work for our many devoted and
skilled co-workers without whom our
achievements would have been impossible
and finally for Alfred Nobel for his
wisdom Institute the prize and the
people Sweden for fantastic novel we
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]